in the lobby of Ramsey's solutions rich
and sunny are with us hey guys how are
you hey
welcome welcome where y'all from
we're from Franklin Indiana it's just
south of Indianapolis Indiana cool
welcome to Nashville and brought
everybody with you to do a debt-free
scream is that right that's right
who's the family tell me about them our
oldest is mourning our middle daughter
is six and she's Eva Bella and our
two-year-old is Ruby fun very fun how
much dad have you guys paid off
we paid off thirty thousand dollars and
just six and a half months way to go
that's awesome making what kind of money
we went from 74 to a hundred and thirty
three thousand here kind of like
doubling your income almost what
happened that happen I went back to work
oh there's that okay what do you guys do
for a living I'm active duty army okay
and I'm an actuary for perfect perfect
well thank you for your service first
thank you very fun cool so what kind of
debt was this we were normal we had a
car loan we had student loans and we had
a little bit on a credit card okay so
tell me what happened six and a half
months ago they started this journey I
started listening to your podcasts and I
just became addicted I had to listen to
I think at that time you had one hour
okay and I just remember thinking what
hour is not enough and then you guys
went to three hours a day I I actually
was listening to a Disney podcast and my
mom was a big Dave Ramsey fan and I I
looked you up and thought okay I'll
listen to this now okay and then I
slowly brought rich on board and you
know we were facing a really volatile
couple of years because I was gonna
finish school and go back to work and
rich was going to be retiring from the
military and so we we knew we didn't
want to start doing that with that
hanging around our head okay so rich
sunny comes in and says I'm listen to
this guy instead of Disney and we're
gonna get out of debt what'd you say
I liked the idea that she was listening
to someone besides this thing she was
completely completely obsessed with
planning our Disney vacation on board
started so a little bit upgrade there
then okay all right that's fun
but then so what did you guys do to get
out of that then we we did I guess what
everyone else did we started out with
you know the envelopes and the
categories and cash only and no credit
and everything and then we just we
stripped everything that we absolutely
could yeah we quit we quit our
retirement investing we cut our grocery
budget we really tried to use every
single tool that's in the Total Money
Makeover all the tools that you lay out
the youth that you say you know this is
what you need to do to get out of debt
we did all of it so Sonny who does
something she just whatever it is she's
gonna do it wide open I can tell that no
that Disney Dave whatever it is way to
go you guys what worked six and a half
months later you're out of debt
yeah how long have you guys been married
nine years just over nine years have you
ever been debt-free while you were
married
no no so now the first time very good
very cool was it worth the sacrifice
definitely it was I tell people you need
to you need to learn to enjoy the
sacrifice because if you can't do that
it's just it's a small part of your life
and every big payment you know we'd be
able to put $3,000 on a credit card or
$3,000 on our yeah on my student loan
payment and I just remember thinking how
great it felt you guys make time
traction there I mean yeah moved it fast
yeah we did very cool well
congratulations you guys thanks for
visiting our offices not quite Disney
but we got free cookies anyway so we
appreciate you coming all the way down
here to do your debt-free scream and I'm
sure Disney's in the offing somewhere
well and and today is actually my 33rd
birthday happy three in debt free oh my
god sing I love it all right rich and
sunny morning Eva Bella and Ruby count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three
well done you guys I love it I love it I
love it